- Présentement,
ça me prendrait 1 heure 39 au
lieu de 30 minutes en voiture.
- Julia Peccia habite à
Montréal-Est. Elle doit
traverser en voiture de 4
à fois 6 fois semaine le pont
Louis-Hippolyte-La Fontaine
pour se rendre sur son lieu
de travail à Bro
La fermeture partielle du pont
l'oblige à changer d'itinéraire.
JULIA PECCIA, résidente de
Montréal-Est
- L'autobus 189 au coin
de la rude la rude la rude la r,
le métro jusqu'à Berri-UQAM.
Ensuite, la ligne orange
jusqu'à Bonaventure et ensuite
l'autobus. J'ai vraiment peur,
là, j'en ai pas d'alternatives
vraiment. J'aimerais ça le
prendre le transport en commun,
mais c'est pas efficace.
- Pour dédommagerédommagerédommr
les automobilistes,
le ministère des Transport
a mis à leur disposition :
une voie réservée pour les
autobus, taxis et covoiturage,
cinq stationnements
incitatifs gratuits,
des navettes d'autobus,
des lignes d'autobus de
la Rive-Sud au métro Longueuil,
et une rame de métro
suppléme
sur la ligne jaune.
Mais pour que la grande
majorité des usagers délaissent
l'auto-solo, l'offre de service,
selon la professeure
Catherine Morency.
CATHERINE MORENCY, professeure
titulaire, Poly Montréal
- C'est qu'il faut offrir des
services les plus directs
possibles, qui ne sont pas pris
dans la congestion, qui
vont noue d'accéder
rapidement à nos destinations
et à plusieurs heures.
- Pour l'instant, les trois
années d'entraves au tunnel
Louis-Hippolyte-La Fontaine
inquiètent tant les résidents
de la Rive-Sud que ceux
de l'île de Montréal.
- C'est déjà assez pénible.
Ça va être encore
plus pénible qu'avant.
- Ça va changer complètement
mon horaire. Il va
que je quitte vers 4 heures
le matin pour venir travailler.
CHRISTOPHER MCCRAY, Asso. pour
mobilité active de Ville-Marie
te que l'augmentation
du trafic vers le pont
Jacques-Cartier, ça va
amener beaucoup de trafic
sur les rues résidentielles.
- En attendant, Julia Peccia
réfléchit sur les différents
trajets qu'elle devra
emprunter à compter du mois
de novembre. Mais encore là,
pas question de déménager
ni de changer d'emploi.
- Ça fait 15 ans que je
travaille là, donc ça ne me
tente pas de changer d'emploi.
- Ici Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-ntréal.ntréal.ntréal.nt.